into the corner rivers for three off the
back iron Jordan the rebound
River for easily we talked about good
shots and keeping possessions of lives
Vijay gets that rebound he gives back at
the ball familiar area and you have to
credit awesome rivers after missing the
first shot way to have the wherewithal
to take the second shot and you didn't
see them shy away from it it's I got
another opportunity to redeem myself
here and this is what this game brings
about to go which is will the ball back
to Beal Hill Drive
oh yeah I talked about having you know
younger guys on the floor right now the
rotation for thorn well he's late he
doesn't ever get over and these are
these are learning moments learning
moments where everyone has to see what's
going on you got a backdoor cut and you
still allow him to get the shot up if
anything necessary if that teens getting
off the ball you do it Lou has over five
guarded by Beal shoots for the win
[Applause]
just this game has brought so much
excitement for me in my lifetime just
this to be here right now the way this
game has gone back and forth
Kida stop make a huge play hit a stop
looks like three straight game winners
in the head here rivers at one end they
let the other now Williams others out